In the early 1800's, German physician, Franz
Joseph Gall spent a lot of time running his
fingers over the scalps of strangers. He wasn't
a hairdresser, he wasn't a masseuse, he wasn't
just like a big fan of heads. He was a phrenologist,
he was the first phrenologist. Gall believed
that a persons personality was linked to their
skull morphology, that its bumps and ridges
indicated aspects of their character. Amazingly
this "science" actually caught on, was widely
practiced for decades, and Gall became something
of a celebrity.
Well, with a head like his, one can see how
he might have been a little bit fixated with
skull shape.
Eventually, phrenology was dismissed as a
cult pseudoscience because it turns out your
cranial contours tell us exactly nothing about
what's happening inside the brain.
And yet! Gall was actually on to something
big, something that we knew nothing about.
Remember, at this point we were just starting
to get consensus that the brain was the source
of self and not like the soul or the heart
or whatever. His lasting and correct proposition
was that different parts of the brain control
specific aspects of our behavior.
Like we talked about last time, there is a
strong link between biological activity and
psychological events. But in addition to the
interplay of chemicals like neurotransmitters
and hormones, a lot of this has to do with
that localized parts of the brain have specific
functions, like vision, movement, memory,
speech, and even facial recognition. Function,
in other words, is localized.
If you could stimulate different parts of
my brain in any way you wanted to– and if
you ask me nicely, I just might let you–
you could control my movements, my memories,
and even my personality. Poke my brain over
here and my arm would twitch, poke here and
I'd remember my first kiss, do it up her and
suddenly I'd be filled with a tremendous Hulk-like
rage!
This is the link between the brain, that physical
hunk of gunk between the ears, and the mind,
the thing that is us, our consciousness, our
behavior, our decisions, our memories, our
selves. Some neuroscientists like to say that
the mind is what the brain does, so one of
the driving questions of psychology and, like,
the human experiment is "How do our brains'
functions tie to the behavior of the mind?"
And you can't even ask the right questions,
let alone get at some of the answers, until
you get to know the brain.
[Intro]
You might have a passing familiarity with
your nervous system, like, "The brain bone
is connected to the spinal cord bone, and
the spinal cord bone is connected to the motoneuron
bone." That's your central nervous system,
and there aren't actually any bones. Your
central nervous system, or just CNS, is what
makes your bodies big decisions. This system
is the command center, and if you mess with
it, things are gonna get weird. There's also
the peripheral nervous system, which is composed
of scout-like sensory neurons that gather
information and report it back to the central
nervous system.
To get a handle on just how physical the roots
of your mind and personality are, how concretely
your nervous system makes you you, let me
tell you a story. The curious case of Phineas
Gage. In 1848, a genial chap named Phineas
Gage was working on the railroad, tamping
gunpowder into a blasting hole with an iron
rod, but the gunpowder ignited.The resulting
explosion caused the rod to shoot like a bullet
up through his left cheek and out of the top
of his head. There's brain in between those
two places, by the way. Amazingly, he stood
up after the accident, and walked over to
a cart, described what had happened, and then
they drove him back to his house, all while
he was conscious.
So the doctor came to examine him, and refused
to believe that a rod had in fact passed through
his head, understandably. Until Phineas started
coughing and an amount of brain that the doctor
described as a teacup-ful fell out of his
head, and the doctor had to accept indeed
what had happened. After a few months of convalescing,
he was pretty much healed up and moving around
like he used to. But his friends were saying
that Phineas was no longer like himself. Yes
he had his memories and his mental abilities,
and he walked and talked and looked the same,
minus an eyeball, whereas the old Phineas
was mild-mannered and soft-spoken, the post-spike-to-the-brain
Phineas was surly and mean-spirited and vulgar.
People started to describe him as "no longer
Gage."
Phineas moved away from America, the scientific
establishment lost contact with him and 12
years later, after a series of seizures he
died at the age of 36. Phineas is a great,
if extreme, example of how function is localized
in the brain and how physical and biological
factors can be reflected in psychological
ways. Of course he is also an excellent example
of how individual studies are not particularly
useful, especially since we have very little
data on what Phineas was actually like before
or even after his accident. Most accounts
are from the months directly after the accident,
and many of them conflict. It's completely
possible that he continued to heal and lived
his remaining years as a happy and productive
citizen.
Intro-psychology texts often paint the simple
picture of Phineas just so we can have a clear
example of the moment when physicians realized
that messing with the brain was messing with
the mind, but it is of course all much more
complicated and Phineas was an actual, real
life person, I feel that we should give him
the nuance and mystery that he deserves.
Now you might have heard that we only used
about 10 percent of our brains, and oh if
that were true, Phineas would lose a quarter
of his and he'd be just fine. And if we could
just harness the rest of that gray mush, we'd
be able to mind read and levitate and get
all Professor X. It's an exciting thought,
as exciting as the idea that I can tell what
kind of tea you like by feeling the bumps
on your head. It is also exactly as wrong.
After watching an hour or so of reality TV,
you'd be forgiven for thinking that some people
are only working at 10 percent brain capacity.
But in actual reality, brain scans show that
nearly every region of the brain lights up
during even simple tasks like walking and
talking. Not only that, but the brain itself
requires 20 percent of all the body's energy,
and it would make little evolutionary sense
to throw much energy away at something that
is only minimally active.
As animals, our capabilities have developed
in part from our brain structures. We're actually
able to trace our evolutionary history as
we come to understand these structures. Less
complex animals have simpler brains designed
for basic functioning and survival: rest,
breathe, eat. Whereas more complex animals
like many mammals possess brains that feel,
remember, reason, and predict. These animals
don't have all new systems. They have new
brain systems built upon old brain systems.
The brain is kind of like a set of Russian
nesting dolls. The outermost wooden doll is
the newest, most detailed and most complex,
but as you go deeper, the dolls become older
and smaller, and simpler, and more generic.
The innermost wooden doll is the oldest, most
basic. It's like a fossil in your head.
This inner core of the brain, sometimes called
the "old brain" still performs for us much
as it did for our early evolutionary ancestors.
It's anchored by the brainstem, the most ancient
and central core of the brain where the spinal
brain enters the skull. Above it, at the base
of the skull, is the medulla. Here, old brain
functions happen automatically without any
conscious effort: the beating of hearts, the
breathing of lungs, that sort of thing. The
pons is perched on the medulla, and it helps
coordinate movement. Above the pons, at the
top of the brainstem, is the thalamus, a pair
of egg-shaped structures that take in sensory
information related to seeing, hearing, touching,
and tasting. The reticular formation is a
finger-shaped nerve network inside the brain
stem that's essential for arousal, which isn't
necessarily what you feel upon seeing a particularly
nice-looking human, but instead refers to
things like sleeping and walking and pain
perception; other important functions. The
baseball-sized cerebellum, or "little brain",
swells from the bottom of the brain stem and
is responsible for non-verbal learning and
memory, the perception of time, and modulating
motions, it controls voluntary movement like
your sweet dance moves, but it also gets impaired
easily under the influence of alcohol, hence
the term "tipsy".
So the old brain systems keep our body's basic
functions running smoothly; the sort of stuff
any animal might need. This is pretty much
where the brain stops for reptiles.
For higher functions, we look to the limbic
system. This includes the amygdala, hypothalamus,
and hippocampus. Sort of a border region of
the brain separating the old brain and the
newer, higher cerebral areas. The amygdala
consists of two lima bean-sized clusters of
neurons and is responsible for memory consolidation
as well as both our greatest fear and hottest
aggression. Stimulate one area of the amygdala,
and a docile family dog suddenly morphs into
a blood thirsty Cujo. Shift that electrode
over just a tiny bit and that dog will be
cowering at butterfly shadow puppets. The
hypothalamus keeps your whole body steady,
regulating body temperatures, circadian rhythms,
and hunger, also helps govern the endocrine
system, especially the pituitary gland. You
should also thank your hypothalamus for allowing
you to feel pleasure and reward. Rats implanted
with electrodes in the reward center of their
hypothalamuses and given ways to self stimulate
those areas will essentially reward themselves
until they collapse or die. So, use with caution.
The final part of the limbic system is the
hippocampus, central to learning and memory,
and if it's damaged, a person may lose their
ability to retain new facts and memories.
Now above all of this is the most advanced
stuff - the stuff that you think of when you
think of the brain - the grey matter. The
two hemispheres of your cerebrum make up about
eighty-five percent of your brain weight,
and oversee your ability to think, speak,
and perceive. The left and right hemispheres
govern and regulate different functions, giving
us a split brain, connected by a structure
called the corpus callosum. So, for instance,
language production is controlled largely
by the left hemisphere, while certain creative
functions are controlled by the right. Though
this has nothing to do with handedness or
people having dominant sides of their brain
being more analytical or creative or whatever
- that's part of what we call pop psychology:
a behavioral disorder in which journalists
and arm chair psychologists use research showing
beautiful, detailed, intimately connected
complexities of your brain to sell newspapers
or reinforce previously held beliefs.
Yes, some tasks are distributed to one side,
but the sides are deeply and constantly connected;
a statement as general as "artistic people
use their right brains" is as useless as saying
"artistic people have particularly bumpy heads".
Finally, covering the left and right hemispheres,
we have the cerebral cortex, a thin layer
of over twenty billion interconnected neurons.
But let's not forget the unsung heroes of
your nervous system: the billions of non-neuron
glial cells, which provide a spider web of
support that surround, insulate, and nourish
the cerebral neurons.
You've probably seen enough brain diagrams
to know that the cerebral cortex's left and
right sides are subdivided into four lobes:
the frontal, parietal, occipital, and temporal,
all separated by especially prominent folds,
or fissures. Each lobe does indeed have its
own set of duties, and would have made Franz
Gall proud.
The frontal lobes, just behind your forehead,
are involved in speaking, planning, judging,
abstract thinking, and as the tale of Phineas
Gage reminds us, aspects of personality. The
parietal lobes receive and process your sense
of touch and body position. At the back of
your head, the occipital lobes receive information
related to sight. And the temporal lobes just
above your ears process sound, including speech
comprehension.
Remember that each hemisphere controls the
opposite side of the body, so my left temporal
lobe processes sounds heard through my right
ear. And within these lobes there are still
more regions that have specialized functions.
Your motor cortex at the rear of your frontal
lobes, for example, controls voluntary movements
and sends messages from the brain out to the
body like "pet that dog!" or "pick up that
mug", while your somatosensory cortex right
behind it processes incoming sensations like
"Oooooh, that doggie is soft!" or "Gah, the
mug is hot!"
The rest of your grey matter is made up of
association areas that are related to higher
mental functions like remembering, thinking,
learning, and speaking. But the thing about
association areas is that unlike your sensory
or motor cortex, you couldn't just poke one
and create a neat response. Association areas
are more subtle; they deal with things like
interpreting and integrating sensory input
and linking up with memories. And they prevail
throughout all four lobes, so brain damage
to different areas will cause very different
results.
A lesion on a specific part of the temporal
lobe may destroy a person's ability to recognize
faces; traumatic memories or overactive hormones
can profoundly affect our behavior and emotions
- all of which remind us how fundamentally
biology and psychology are intertwined. And
there are few more fascinating examples of
this than how we sense and perceive the world
around us, so that's where we're gonna pick
up next week.
For now, if you were paying attention, you
learned the basics of the central nervous
system, specifically the brain, which can
be understood in terms of old or of more evolutionary
ancestral structures, along with the limbic
system, and new structures, which include
lobes, cortices, and association areas.
Thanks for watching this lesson in Crash Course
Psychology, which was brought to you by The
Air Show, Midnight House Elves on Etsy, and
Daniel Vasey, thank you so much to all of
you. If you would like to sponsor an episode
and give your own shout-out, you can learn
about that and other perks available at Subbable.com.
This episode was written by Kathleen Yale,
edited by Blake de Pastino and myself, and
our consultant is Dr. Ranjit Bhagwat. Our
editor and director is Nicholas Jenkins, Michael
Aranda is our sound designer and our graphic
team is Thought Cafe.